ça y est c'est le thé confinement enfin
en france c'est la première étape du
déconfinement et on croise bien sûr très
fort les doigts pour que le
déconfinement se passe aussi bien que
possible pour que les entreprises
retrouvent peu à peu leur activité et
n'ai pas besoin de licencier leurs
employés et surtout pour que la pandémie
covit 19 ne repartent pas de plus belle
avec une seconde vague comme en a parlé
dans le premier épisode de cette série
la variable clé pour le contrôle de la
pandémie elle fameux taux de
reproduction effectif rt si arte est
inférieur à 1
alors la pandémie sera sous contrôle et
on n'aura pas à se soucier d'une seconde
vague et donc d'un risque de ce long
confinement
mais si rt est supérieur à 1 alors il y
aura à nouveau une croissance
exponentielle des infections des
hospitalisations et des décès par kobe
de 19 gares drt inférieur à 1 est
absolument critique ou comme mythique ac
marseille c'est la télé explique très
bien dans ce grave peut-être un peu trop
compliqué perte est supérieure à 1 c'est
mal rt inférieure à 1
c'est bien en fait plutôt que de juste
croiser les doigts et prier pour que
arte sur inférieure à 1
il sera beaucoup plus judicieux de
piloter le déconfinement pour garder rt
légèrement inférieur à 1
autrement dit on peut imaginer que notre
planète est une sorte de vaisseau
spatial et qu'on dispose de plein de
réglages possibles du vaisseau spatial
chaque bouton correspond à une
intervention possible par exemple on
peut choisir l'ouverture ou la fermeture
des écoles des commerces et des
événements sociaux
on peut augmenter ou diminuer la
quantité de tests et de masques ainsi
que la réglementation pour forcer le
test systématique ou le port de masques
systématique pour la population ou
encore on peut augmenter ou diminuer les
appelle à des gestes barrières en
investissant plus ou moins dans la
communication scientifique chaque
réglage a ensuite des effets sur le
bien-être économique social et
psychologique des habitants du vaisseau
de manière très grossière moins de
confinement moins de tests et moins de
communication ce sera mieux pour ce
bien-être
mais ces réglages ont aussi un effet sur
le fameux taux de reproduction effectifs
- de confinement moins de tester moins
de communication c'est aussi et surtout
un taux de reproduction effectif
rt plus grand bien piloter le
déconfinement reviendra typiquement un
maximisée
le bien-être de la population tout en
gardant un taux de reproduction effectif
rt légèrement inférieur à 1
dit comme ça
paraître facile cependant il y a
plusieurs grosses difficultés dans le
pilotage de ce déconfinement le premier
c'est que l'efficacité des différentes
interventions comme la fiabilité des
tests groupe et les effets d'une
légifération sur le port de masques ou
l'impact d'une adoption massive des
applications de notification à
l'exposition l'efficacité de ces
différentes interventions est encore
plein d'incertitudes
même si toutes ces interventions vont
certainement réduire rt on ne sait pas
encore très bien à quel point réduiront
rt tout comme il est d'ailleurs
difficile d'estimer leur impact sur le
bien-être économique social et
psychologique de la population en fait
un instar du problème des traitements
contre 8,19 on est là dans un dilemme
exploration exploitation pour piloter au
mieux notre vaisseau il va nous falloir
comprendre au mieux comment les
différents réglages du vaisseau modifie
le comportement du vaisseau même si une
telle exploration des différents
réglages aura aussi des conséquences
néfastes sur l'état du vaisseau
il y à un juste compromis à trouver
entre tenté des manoeuvres pour en
savoir plus et courir le risque que ces
manoeuvres endommagent rapidement le
vaisseau ok ça c'est le premier problème
dont on a déjà beaucoup parlé dans cette
série en insistant notamment beaucoup
sur le problème des contaminations très
symptomatique pour lesquelles certaines
interventions comme le test systématique
des individus symptomatique seront
inefficaces mais il y à un autre
problème tout aussi importants dont on
n'a pas encore beaucoup parler qui vient
du fait que le nombre
rt n'est pas bien connue pour appel à
l'instant t
rt et le nombre moyen d'individus qu'une
personne infectée contaminés ce n'est
absolument pas quelque chose que l'on
peut observer directement
souvenez vous on a déjà un mal fou à
détecter les individus contaminés
jusque là la plupart des études qui
estime rt en tout cas celle que j'ai vu
passer s'appuie surtout sur le nombre de
cas confirmés
le nombre d'hospitalisations et le
nombre de morts de kobe 10 nov
malheureusement toutes ces mesures ont
de gros défauts le nombre de cas
confirmés dépend fortement de notre
capacité à tester le nombre
d'hospitalisations ne tient compte que
des cas graves et le nombre de morts à
plusieurs semaines de retard à cause du
délai entre l'infection et le décès dès
lors piloter le déconfinement c'est un
peu comme conduire une voiture dans un
brouillard avec plusieurs secondes de
décalage entre la position de la vitesse
actif de la voiture est ce qu'on peut
voir nous en tant que conducteur à
travers la vitre je ne sais pas si vous
avez déjà joué un jeu vidéo de voitures
qui lag mais c'est pas idéal voire c'est
tout simplement beaucoup trop dangereux
par dans le cas de la vraie voiture pas
du jeu vidéo
alors en fait dans un épisode précédent
on a déjà vu que les applications de
notification à l'exposition pouvait être
d'une grande utilité pour estimer le
taux de reproduction effectif en effet
on peut estimer au moins en première
approximation plus le taux de
reproduction effectif est proportionnel
au nombre moyen de contact d'un individu
6,8 au déconfinement ce nombre triple
ici c'est au taux de reproduction
effectif était de 0,5 avant
déconfinement alors on pourra deviner
que le déconfinement a fait pas et rt au
dessus de 1
bien sûr des méthodes plus sophistiquées
pourrait être utilisé en étudiant en
particulier les cas confirmés et les
contacts des cas confirmés
il peut aussi étudier la durée des
contacts ainsi que la proximité des
contacts en exploitant ensuite des
modèles plus raffinés on pourrait alors
avoir une meilleure estimation de rt et
réduire notre incertitude sur ce nombre
mais ces données des applications de
notification à l'exposition seront
probablement insuffisante des méthodes
plus efficaces et plus fiable pour
estimer rt en temps réel semble requise
aujourd'hui je vais surtout insisté sur
une piste qui me semblent prometteuses
pour aider à estimer rt en temps réel et
en particulier en amont des cas
confirmés et des hospitalisations
comme vous l'aurez compris ça a à voir
avec les toilettes
en fait pour bien piloter le
déconfinement il va être utile de savoir
si savez le truc qui sont habituellement
mauvais eh bien ça va être utile de
savoir s'il sent vraiment mauvais goût
et on sait que ça va sentir mon verdict
pour l'odorat
la question c'est de savoir est-ce que
ça sent mauvais pour le déconfinement
aussi la première publication à ce sujet
à ma connaissance nous vient d'un cas
d'étude aux pays bas qui a analysé les
eaux usées dans cette ville est un
aéroport de façon remarquable les
néerlandais ont remarqué une très bonne
corrélation entre le nombre de cas
confirmés dans les différentes villes et
la densité des traces du sart skov 2
dans les égouts sarr skov de et le nom
du virus qui causent des maladies
bovines dit ce n'est qu'en partant
quotidiennement à la trace des
déjections dans les eaux usées les
chercheurs néerlandais ont pu se sentir
venir les foyers d'épidémie qu'ovide 19
alors l'étude néerlandaise seuls
seraient à prendre avec des pincettes
puisque seulement 16 échantillons ont
été utilisés cependant des études
similaires ont été réalisées maintenant
un peu partout dans le monde
le pfl en suisse on université a
notamment lancé un projet de
surveillance des eaux usées qui confirme
la capacité à détecter des augmentations
des nombres de cas par jour et ce
parfois des jours voire des semaines
avant que ces cas soient confirmés par
des tests
même son de cloche du côté de cet
article publié suite à une étude sur
paris je cite ce travail suggère qu'un
suivi quantitatif des génomes sarr skov
2 dans les eaux usées devrait apporter
des informations additionnelles
importantes pour mieux surveiller la
circulation de sascoc de à l'échelle
locale et régionale
cette technique d'analysé des égouts a
aussi a été utilisée aux états unis en
australie et sans doute dans beaucoup
d'autres pays à travers le monde avec
des résultats prometteurs un peu partout
ainsi en prenant chaque jour une grosse
cuillerées d'eau usée puis en amplifiant
les saloperies dans cette cuir et en
particulier les arn du virus sarr skov
de grâce à des méthodes qpcr il semble
possible d'entrevoir le bout du tunnel
ou du moins de mieux vérifier que le
pilotage de notre vaisseau nous emmène
bien vers le bout du tunnel
les eaux usées pourrait techniquement
nous permettre de littéralement remonter
un peu plus près de la source est
identifiée les foyers suspect de covile
19 voilà qui pourrait permettre
d'imposer des mesures très localisés
pour contenir la pandémie sans avoir à
confiner toute la population si je
reprends l'analogie du vaisseau c'est
voudrait dire que pour éteindre un feu
dans une salle du vaisseau arrosera
uniquement cette salle est pas
l'entièreté du vaisseau ceci serait tout
aussi efficace pour éteindre le feu et
éviterait toutes sortes de dommages
collatéraux ailleurs dans le vaisseau
pour identifier les foyers suspect bruce
king intuit aux sur qui je n'ai pas
trouvé beaucoup d'information propose un
modèle jouait pour illustrer ce qui
pourrait être fait on pourrait commencer
par tester les grands canaux d'eau usée
et si un grand canal et contaminé alors
on pourrait tester les affluents de ce
grand canal et remonter ainsi petit à
petit vers les égouts en amont qui sont
issus de moins de foyers en supposant
qu'il n'y a qu'une seule habitation
contaminés cette approche pourrait en
principe permettre de retrouver cette
habitation avec une approche
dichotomique c'est-à-dire qui diviserait
par deux à chaque test le nombre
d'habitations suspecte il suffirait
ensuite de longues en base 2 du nombre
d'habitants qui reversent leurs eaux
usées dans le canal principal pour
identifier l'habitation contaminés si ce
canal principal correspond à un million
d'habitants
il suffira alors de 20 tests pour
identifier l'habitation contaminés et
pour ceux qui sont perspicaces parmi
vous oui cette approche dichotomique est
en fait extrêmement semblable à l'idée
des tests groupe est alors bien sûr il
ne s'agit là que d'un modèle très
idéalisée
en pratique accéder aux eaux usées d'un
groupe d'habitations en particulier est
limité notamment d'un point de vue
logistique par la facilité d'accès à ces
eaux usées typiquement via les bouches
gecko néanmoins cette approche pourrait
être utile pour mieux identifier les
zones à risque pour peut-être ensuite
mieux cibler des individus à risque et
leur demander de se faire tester en
priorité mais pour en arriver jusque là
il va falloir investir dans l'analyse
des eaux usées or de ce que je comprends
même si malheureusement les données
auxquelles j'ai pu avoir accès sont très
parcellaires
il ne semble pas encore y avoir deux
dispositifs en place pour permettre
cette identification de foyers suspect à
grande échelle
encore et testés individuellement les
patients grâce à leurs déjections
une telle approche pourrait après tout
être plus efficaces que les tests
classiques dont le taux de faux négatifs
semble malheureusement loin d'être
négligeable en effet le test plus
classique appelée frottis naso pharyngé
pcr consiste à prélever des particules
au fond du nez à l'aide d'une longue
tige cette opération paraît très
déplaisantes voire douloureuse mais
surtout cette opération peut être peu
efficace en effet le prélèvement semble
associée à une grande probabilité
d'échec peut être de 10% voire peut-être
de presque 50% ce qui serait vraiment
horrible mais ne serait peut-être pas si
étonnant vu que ça dépend finalement
beaucoup
du coup de main du médecin et de
l'attitude du patient dans ce contexte
explorer des tests alternatifs semble
désirable il existe de nombreuses
propositions de test alternatif à base
de crachats ou de scanner de la poitrine
par exemple mais vu qu'aujourd'hui on
parle des eaux usées et de toilettes
il est intéressant de s'attarder sur ce
qui sort plus naturellement du corps
humain
malheureusement selon cette étude dans
nature les prises de sang ils urinent ne
semble pas contenir les traces de sarov
2 cependant le caca par les excréments
oui en fait la concentration de sart
skov de dans les excréments semble tout
à fait comparable à celui dont les
frottis naso pharyngé bien effectuer ou
plus précisément les excréments sont
pleins non pas du virus lui même avec
son enveloppe protectrice mais de la rn
du virus c'est-à-dire de la molécule
contenant l'information génétique du
virus qui se trouve à l'intérieur de
l'enveloppé protectrice et ça c'est
doublement une bonne nouvelle ainsi non
seulement il est possible de détecter
des traces du virus et donc de
l'infection des patients dans les selles
mais de plus ceci suggère que ces
excréments ne serait pas contagieux il
n'y aurait donc pas de risque de
contamination fécale orale est oui dit
fécale orale
c'est le terme consacré lui paraît alors
bien sûr ceci n'est pas une raison pour
vous [ __ ] des excréments partout où
pour vous exposer volontairement à des
excréments sachant notamment que
d'autres études sont un peu plus
réservés ceci dit a priori s'il
fonctionne correctement votre odorat
devrait déjà vous permettre de ressentir
du dégoût pour ce genre de choses
et de vous en tenir éloignés et si vous
pouvez vous laver les mains après avoir
fait vos besoins je pense que ça ne sera
pas de refus pour quiconque en fait de
façon intrigante cette étude et d'autres
suggèrent que la rn25 skov 2 est
détectable y compris lorsque les tests
naso pharyngé sont négatifs ces tests
pourraient ainsi être complémentaires
voire préférable aux tests naso pharyngé
même si bon il faudra du coup remplacer
une expérience déplaisante comme se
[ __ ] une tige dans le nez par une
autre expérience déplaisante comme
amassé sa crotte après être passé aux
toilettes
une remarque importante toutefois pour
finir la rn du virus reste détectable
dans les excréments des patients pendant
parfois trois semaines après l'infection
y compris après la disparation des
symptômes et ça c'est important à
prendre en compte notamment dans
l'analyse des eaux usées car ça pourrait
correspondre à signaler des risques chez
une personne qui pourrait en fait ne
plus être à risque ni de contagion ni de
besoin d'hospitalisation
ceci dit cette étude sur paris suggère
que la diminution du taux des reines de
sarov 2 dans les égouts parisiens colle
très bien avec la diminution du nombre
de cas confirmés constaté dans la
capitale française
on a vu aujourd'hui l'importance du
suivi de la pandémie pour mieux estimer
le fameux taux de reproduction effectif
rt qui est une variable clé pour assurer
un déconfinement sécurisé
malheureusement rtl lui même très
difficile à estimer
surtout en temps réel le suivi des
égouts semble être particulièrement
prometteur pour permettre une meilleure
estimation de rt nous encore avec
davantage d'efforts il pourrait être
possible de mieux localiser les foyers
de contamination avant qu'il n'explose
pour ainsi mieux cibler les tests des
individus suspects et déterminer des
interventions plus ciblées pour éviter
autant que possible de dégrader le
bien-être économique social et
psychologique du plus grand nombre
en fait l'analyse des excréments
pourrait même être d'une utilité bien
plus grande encore car elle pourrait
conduire à des dépistages plus fiable
des cas de co vite 19 le virus sarr skov
de fait chier mais c'est peut-être l'une
de ces vulnérabilités